bonjour françois grabovski merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
on vient de voir les manifestations de
propriétaires de bars et restaurants se
multiplient vous les comprenez oui tout
à fait rouler rouler contre ans et d'un
point de vue économique c'est
extrêmement compliqué ils ont déjà avec
une première vague qui les a mis en en
difficulté là ils sont à nouveau
sollicités pour restreindre leurs
activités de façon assez brutale donc on
peut aussi tâté de crainte que brossoit
une situation qui soit qu'ils soient
extrêmement compliqué surtout pour elle
par ses des entrepreneurs leur leur
établissement c'est leur vie mon corps
si on se met à leur place
en tout à fait après aujourd'hui on dit
quand même une crise majeure sanitaires
anouk et malheureusement il ya des
mesures qui sont nécessaires pour
limiter le risque de demeurer sous le
rap et c'est que à la fin les personnes
vulnérables qui attrape le virus décède
toujours donc malheureusement il ya et
l'opposition entre les mesures
sanitaires qui vise à éviter les décès
et des mesures économiques
on essaie de limiter puisque l'impact
économique pourrait aussi lui à moyen et
long terme voire un impact délétère sur
l'état de santé global de la population
françois cravoisier paris a dépassé
certains critères établis par le
ministère de la santé et pourrait passer
bientôt le seuil d'alerté maximale de
nouvelles mesures pourraient être pressé
prochain joie prudence nécessaire on
alarmisme démesurée il ya quelques temps
visés qui urge de inquiet puisque la
situation les chiffres montraient pas
d'évolution rapide d'une nouvelle
nouveau pic épidémique
aujourd'hui on est complètement au début
d'un réel pic épidémique
donc il faut être réellement vigilant et
puis la roue puisque vigilant il faut
vraiment être très prudent les taux de
contamination peuvent être très élevées
on l'a vu lors de la
vingt et une personnes contaminées 3,4
ça peut aller très vite dont des
personnes fragiles et si les
établissements de santé sont dépassées
dans la prise en charge en réanimation
urgences vitales
ça peut être dramatique on peut voir un
nombre de morts absolument incroyable
charge l à nous de respecter les mesures
qui s'imposent alors bien sûr et des
mesures collectives de rassemblement et
cetera c'est aussi des mesures qui sont
maintenant localisé on essaie de
circonscrire le problème au mieux de
rester au graphique dans des secteurs à
éviter un confinement généralisée
pourquoi parler de leur confinement
généraliser je me permets de vous couper
la parole parce qu'elle en début de
semaine olivier ferrand a déclaré pas de
rang confinement nationale préventif
avant noël elisabeth bornes
elle a dit on fait tout pour éviter un
recond films en général mais avec ce
virus en explorer 1 c'est la cacophonie
qui croire et tout le monde en fait
puisqu'on prend les décisions aux dires
où les décisions sont prises en fonction
des chiffres et de l'évolution
si les confinements localiser les
mesures qui sont prises de façon locale
géographique ou sur des secteurs et le
rappellent les gestes d'arrière si
individuellement chacun prend sa
responsabilité de les appliquer au mieux
et qu'on limite on parlait
d'aplatissement de la courbe lors de la
première vague ça s'applique fait à
cette solution second pic et pic
épidémique par an donc si on arrive à
aplatir la courbe et a limité
on n'aura pas besoin de re confier de
façon générale et c'est ce qu'il faut
éviter absolument puisque ce serait
catastrophique vous font croire tout le
monde parle
pardon mais mais
pendant ça c'est difficile de comprendre
un même du côté de votre corporation le
corps médical qui semblent divisés je
vous donne un exemple le professeur
philippe juvin le site qui a dit il faut
commander dix mille respirateur
immédiatement mettre en place des
hôpitaux éphémère immédiatement c'était
sur rtl et puis pour le professeur jean
françois toussaint je cite il y à 90%
des 10000 à 16000 cas positifs par jour
qui sont des gens qui ne sont pas
transmetteur voir qu'ils sont guéris
c'est une maladie 100 malades il l'a dit
sur sur ses news pardon mais on s'y perd
un peu
qui est ce qu'il faut croire là aussi
vous comprenez que la population
française ne comprends plus rien il ya
de quoi désorienter quand même mais je
comprends tout à fait et c'est ce type
de message qui est désolant tout le
monde puisque un prophète
la réalité c'est qu'on est incapable
aujourd'hui même si on a de plus en plus
d'informations être certain des faits on
découvre encore un certain nombre de
choses sur ce virus qui évolue lui-même
dans sa vie et dans cette transmission
le sait qu'en france mais bien avoir une
réponse est claire on aimerait dire
gardera pour deux mois qu'il faut même
telle et telle mesure la réalité en
médecine de façon générale et moi je
toujours surpris de voir des confrères
qui me disent je suis sûr et certain ça
se passerait comme ça vous avez pu le
voir certains qui se sont exprimés et
quelques mois on le regrette peut-être
pas mais se sont complètement plantés
excusez-moi ch
on ne sait pas tout on voit au fur et à
mesure donc je dis pas qu'il faut
l'écouter tout le monde je dis que les
deux sont possibles et qu'il faut
regarder en allant aujourd'hui pas
besoin de confinement généralisée on
confine localement géographique on
apprend et qu'on a des nouvelles
informations
c'est comme ça que ça marche ce soit en
médecine en médecine de façon générale
ou sur la santé on apprend au fur et à
mesure et puis on en apprend puis on met
en place des protocoles et des mesures
qui sont les plus adaptées à ce pont
c'est le regard se confirme
sachant que le taux d'occupation des
lits de réanimation vient de franchir la
barre des 30 % en ile-de-france on
surcharge des hôpitaux franciliens
est ce que c'est possible une surcharge
basse et oui c'est possible sinon
mettrait pas toutes ces mesures
préventives
c'est justement pour éviter ça éviter
que les
service soit à nouveau complètement
engorgé de réanimation qu'on observe
d'un nombre de décès qu'ils soient pas
forcément tolérable donc voilà il faut
certes anticipé sur le plan de
l'organisation des soins dans les
hôpitaux en mettant en place un certain
nombre de voix la embêtant parce que les
mesures qui permettront d'accueillir
plus rapidement possible et au plus
grand nombre les personnes et dans la
vie de tous les jours en respectant les
gestes barrières on entend presque plus
parler pour moi parce qu'on est sur des
mesures un petit peu charismatique le
masque que la fermeture des bars mais
vous savez les mails et les mesures
barrières restent le plus efficace
différenciation sociale à vache demain
or de masques voilà et en élite en
dessous merci françois à graben ce qui
est d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
spécialiste en santé publique